hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 soy santiago lópez gonzález la
violencia se recrudece en buenaventura
uno de los principales puertos de
colombia desde finales del año hasta la
fecha los enfrentamientos entre las
bandas armadas por el control del
territorio han sumido a esta ciudad en
una nueva oleada de conflictos los
tiroteos son constantes y los homicidios
en el pasado mes de enero se triplicaron
si lo comparamos con el año pasado
varias familias tuvieron que dejar sus
viviendas en esta zona o en las zonas
más afectadas de esta ciudad la
defensoría del pueblo de colombia
registró el desplazamiento forzado de al
menos 650 personas y más allá de estos
desplazamientos los habitantes de
buenaventura denuncian que comunidades
enteras permanecen confinadas y con
muchísimas restricciones de movimiento
por miedo a la violencia que hay en esta
ciudad pero a pesar de los
reconocimientos de los hechos en las
últimas semanas la violencia azota
buenaventura desde hace muchas décadas
atrás la ciudad es el principal puerto
de colombia en la costa
pacífico pero su población vive inmersa
en la pobreza y sin paz los actores
armados han cambiado a lo largo del
tiempo pero la situación parece que no
mejora tenemos con nosotros aquí en la
entrevista de france 24 al lyon
rentería él es un joven líder social que
lucha por la paz y por los derechos
humanos allí en la ciudad de
buenaventura
rentería también es cantante es rapero y
a través de su música hace llegar las
denuncias sociales al resto de su país
colombia
leonard muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en la entrevista de france
24 y quiero que nos ponga en contexto
para los televidentes que están fuera de
las fronteras de colombia que es lo que
está ocurriendo en buenaventura
exactamente
una aventura hoy vive un flagelo difícil
de violencia pero para comprender el
ejercicio lo que pasa aquí es necesario
entender y comprender
qué buena aventura porque las realidades
de violencia casi siempre se dan de
acuerdo algunas realidades valga la
redundancia buenaventura es un
territorio y con el pacífico colombiano
que tiene un 80 por ciento de pobreza 63
por ciento de desempleo una ciudad que
no tiene agua
sino aproximadamente unas 6 horas
promedio haciendo un promedio día de por
medio
sumaba eso pese a tener 11 cuencas
hidrográficas
la situación de violencia es bien fuerte
pero la situación es compleja y son
múltiples los factores como usted lo
describe y como también mencionaba yo en
la introducción del programa pero
concretamente en las últimas semanas qué
es lo que ha provocado el
recrudecimiento del conflicto allí en
este puerto del pacífico en buenaventura
ha tenido los grupos ilegales siempre
dos bandos contrarios que se disputan en
territorio aquí lo que hay es una
disputa por el territorio la disputa
territorial pues con los fines que todo
el mundo ya sabe con el fin del control
del territorio para actividades ilegales
eso lo sabemos todos y lo que se está
dando es una disputa por quién controla
qué territorio y eso es lo que en
definitiva está ocurriendo en el
distrito una mente dura y lo que hace
que la población que esté en el medio
pues termine siendo la población más
afectada a partir de esta realidad
y una ante todas estas dificultades uno
se imagina que las oportunidades para la
población de buenaventura para la gente
que vive allí especialmente para los
jóvenes deben de ser muy escasas cómo
afecta entonces esta situación a los
habitantes de la ciudad que ya con el
contexto en el que viven se muestran
vulnerables la realidad de
vulnerabilidad hace que con facilidad
por ejemplo los distintos actores que se
disputan la situación del conflicto pues
tengan un punto en la medida que como
los jóvenes no tienen acceso a los
derechos fundamentales a la salud
educación cultura deporte entonces
terminan los grupos ilegales por
ofrecerle a los jóvenes aquellas
oportunidades negativas estas que el
estado en forma no ofrece entonces por
ejemplo termina pasando que
y los jóvenes que no tienen acceso a
oportunidades pues un grupo ilegal le
ofrece género un arma y terminan por
volcarse hacia esas estructuras armadas
y terminan por generar una violencia
en la que siguen siendo el centro de los
jóvenes porque los que disparan en su
mayoría son jóvenes y los que reciben
los disparos pues en su mayoría también
son jóvenes
y no hay un ejercicio real
en términos de atención institucional
gubernamental que permita por ejemplo
resolver esas necesidades en el término
de garantía de derecho que tanto
requiere una aventura para poder avanzar
hace un ejercicio de transformación
social
qué es lo que en definitiva pasa acá
situación de pobreza vulnerabilidad
abandono estatal territorios colmados
por por la desesperanza por la falta de
acceso a servicios de calidad por la
falta acceso a la salud la educación
entre otras pues terminan siendo usados
esas realidades que viven por los grupos
ilegales para poder generar toda una
situación que conlleva los jóvenes
exactamente a incluirse en la violencia
ya usted lo mencionaba una de las
principales denuncias que queda sobre la
mesa que usted hace que también uno ve
en las marchas en las protestas que hay
en buenaventura sobre la situación
actual en este puerto del pacífico es
que sufren de un olvido constante por
parte de las autoridades tanto
departamentales como el gobierno central
desde bogotá cuales entonces son esas
causas estructurales que influyen en las
dificultades que está atravesando
buenaventura el día de hoy
bueno te digo en el avatar es una causa
primordial del estado no ha invertido en
buenaventura pese a que una aventura le
representa mucho recurso vamos hablando
casi 5 billones
anuales que le da una aventura
sin mensuales que le dan
al país estamos hablando de un abandono
estatal bueno por aquí está el principal
puerto por donde entra y sale casi el 60
por ciento de la carga y esa carga que
entra y sale por aquí se va es decir la
riqueza se pasea por aquí pero sin
embargo no alcanzan los otros factores
lo que yo te digo el factor de la
pobreza o sea la pobreza es uno de los
factores y una de las causas que termina
facilitando la generación de la
violencia
que es como otro aspecto importante y yo
diría que en esas dos se resume un poco
el ejercicio esa pobreza y el abandono
estructural bueno hay un tercer factor
que es el factor que de alguna u otra
manera se relaciona en el factor del
racismo estructural que es común no se
garantiza el acceso a derechos a
personas que en su mayoría son
afrodescendientes entre ellas los
territorios afrodescendientes situación
recorrido por el país ya les cuenta que
en la mayoría de lugares donde hay más
vulnerabilidad donde hay más pobreza y
menos acceso a los derechos pues son los
lugares donde habitan las comunidades
afrodescendientes entonces el abandono
estatal el racismo estructural y la
pobreza se convierten en tres pilares
que lamentablemente contienen a esta
ciudad a vivir en esa realidad que vive
o
leonard y porque esa actividad económica
no termina re distribuyéndose en la
ciudad de buenaventura porque siendo el
principal puerto de colombia en el
pacífico es la puerta de entrada a
mercados tan gigantescos como el mercado
de china y otros mercados en el sudeste
asiático
primero la
repartición inequitativa de los esposos
la contraprestación del puerto está 80
por ciento para la nación nación
es decir se centraliza en bogotá y el
20% para buenaventura es decir que una
menos cantidad aprecia que el territorio
dónde está el puerto
el segundo aspecto es el ejercicio
corrupción que no sólo se da en lo local
sino que se da en lo departamental y se
da en lo
y nacional
y será en lo nacional entonces en ese
sentido queda claro que la corrupción
estatal no permite la inversión social
que se requiere en los territorios
entonces nos encontramos con que
sencillamente en lo local la mayoría de
los alcaldes los últimos cinco alcaldes
se han ido y han salido vía alcaldía a
la cárcel por la mala ejecución de
recursos y por el robo el recurso
público es decir que se hayan robado las
oportunidades de buenaventura aquí en lo
local pero ha sido orquestado muchas
veces con el gobierno departamental y el
gobierno nacional entonces todas esas
realidades atrás que es un territorio
por los recursos no se invierten porque
el tema de la corrupción atraviesa
absolutamente todo que es otro factor
que lamentablemente termina afectando
este territorio como lo afecta
en el año 2016 colombia firmó un acuerdo
de paz con la entonces guerrilla de las
farc y dentro de ese acuerdo uno de los
apartes trataba de enmendar algunas de
las causas estructurales de la violencia
que vive colombia pero a pesar de eso
tal parece que de acuerdo a lo que usted
nos describe que la situación en
buenaventura no ha mejorado mucho usted
en ese momento tuvo esperanzas de que
este acuerdo de paz trajera algo de paz
para esta región del pacífico colombiano
la verdad es que cuando tenemos de
acuerdo yo no vi esperanza de paz al
menos no en una aventura porque el
acuerdo no se firmó con los grupos
paramilitares y con las bandas
criminales no sé qué más acuerdos
tenemos con las farc y la fuerza su
presencia está consciente estaba
concentrada en la zona rural de una
aventura y no en lo urbano por ende ese
acuerdo de paz
si bien contemplado un ejercicio de
posibilidad de desmantelación de grupos
ilegales distinto a la guerrilla con la
que se firmó el acuerdo pues
sencillamente no nos iba a traer la paja
nosotros porque la paz se firmó con las
farc y no con los grupos que están aquí
las bandas criminales en ese sentido
pues aparte se firmó debería facilitar
el mayor escenario para que se pudiera
avanzar hacer ejercicio de
desmantelación de la ilegalidad en
buenaventura pero no se da porque
hubiera acuerdo no se cumple pero hay
que entender que de facto no se iba a
dar el cese de la violencia en una
aventura porque no era un acuerdo
firmado con las balas criminales de aquí
por eso no de facto no iba a pasar decir
nuevas de movilización de esas
estructuras que están en los barrios
porque no hacían parte de las farc
y en el segundo aspecto es porque
sencillamente se habla entre la puerta
una posibilidad de desmantelación de los
grupos ilegales y es además de la acción
tampoco se ha hecho porque el acuerdo
sabemos que está quedado y que el
gobierno no ha tenido el interés de
sacar adelante este acuerdo y por ende
pues la situación de pacificar los
territorios pues lamentablemente está
quedando casi que en el aire
leonard así las cosas la respuesta que
ha dado el gobierno del presidente iván
duque se basa en la lucha militar en una
confrontación directa contra el
narcotráfico esto qué consecuencias ha
traído para la ciudad de buenaventura
que en muchos casos se ha visto
militarizada
pues la población civil ha sido la más
afectada y ha sido la más afectada
sencillamente porque es una población
pobre lo que pasa es que le ponen
fiscalizaciones me dio un conflicto eso
sigue generando más confinamiento sigue
generando más situaciones y puede
aparentemente traer una calma pero
sacarme el momentáneo porque recordemos
que los procesos de intervención militar
tienen un periodo y después de ese
periodo bueno llegan todo se calma se
van y después al tiempo vuelve y se
revive la situación y se revive por lo
que hemos dicho todo este tiempo porque
no hay inversión social que pueda
ofrecerle otra oportunidad a quienes
terminan cayendo en los grupos ilegales
leonard rentería líderes sociales en la
ciudad de buenaventura al puerto de
colombia en el pacífico gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en la entrevista
de france 24 de ustedes muchas gracias
por la sintonía siga con nuestra
programación
[Música]